je m'appelle Joker et je suis né à
Bruxelles en 1961 de parents réfugiés
politiques hongrois mon père a fui la
Hongrie en 1946 et ma mère en 1956 suite
à la révolution hongroise depuis la
peste
et donc mes parents sont rencontrés en
Belgique et la vie est très difficile
parce qu'en fait ils n'ont pas de
famille et
ils sont arrivés avec rien
et donc je n'ai le 18 1961 et
la billet terriblement compliquée et
donc ils envisagent de rejoindre la
famille qui est parti au Canada
pour pour avoir pour être entouré pour
avoir
de la famille autour de donc
dans ce but là il m'envoie chez les
parents maternelle et chez moi mon oncle
en Ontario et ils ont une plantation de
tabac et pour moi le Canada ça va être
la découverte des grands espaces
je vais courir avec ma chaîne à travers
les champs de blé de maïs la plantation
de tabac il y aura une forêt où je vais
me construire une aventure un étang où
je vais nager avec ma chienne et donc
c'était époque de ma vie est
terriblement importante parce que je
vais apprendre le mouvement bouger je
vais courir pieds nus que ce soit en
hiver ou que ce soit en été là-bas en
Ontario près de London Ontario et donc
à l'âge vers l'âge de 6 ans je vais
retourner en Belgique parce que mon père
envisage de pouvoir retourner vivre
ensemble en gris si le communisme quitte
la mécanique et donc pour moi c'est le
c'est le choc parce que j'apprends à
parler hongrois et à anglais à ce
moment-là de ma vie et des grands
espaces de nature je me retrouve dans
une ville de béton et de briques et donc
c'est un choc pour moi et donc toute mon
adolescence
ma vie va se faire dans le mouvement je
vais trouver le mon équilibre
cet équilibre qui vient du fait que il
voit il faut pouvoir arrêter de faire du
bavardage d'esprit et
se nettoyer la tête et moi ce truc là je
l'ai par le sport par le mouvement et
donc c'est ce qui va m'amener à avoir
une section de la moelle épinière à
l'âge juste un peu après le dash de 20
ans donc je quitte l'armée j'ai fait les
10 mois d'armée et je me retrouve donc
de retour à la vie
civile et j'ai accident et en fait mon
objectif dans ma vie c'était de
retourner vivre au Canada et de devenir
joueur de hockey professionnel ma vie
c'était ça dans mon rêve de de
d'adolescent
et donc
j'ai cet accident et
je me retrouve à me réveiller après une
semaine de coma allongée sur le ventre
et on m'annonce que j'ai une section de
la moelle épinière et pour moi je veux
dire à cette pop là il y avait pas
Internet et donc si par contre vous
intéresser au corps humain ou à tout
autre sujet il fallait aller chercher un
bouquin à la bibliothèque ou acheter un
livre et donc moi j'étais même pas dans
la conscience de ma colonne vertébrale
il y a encore moins de ma moelle
épinière j'étais pas conscient de du
fonctionnement de mon corps tout ce que
j'appréciais c'était c'était de vivre en
fait et de me nourrir de cette vie et
donc
je me réveille et
le temps passe et je vais dans un centre
de rééducation où je vais passer 13 mois
de ma vie un an et un mois de ma à
essayer de me comment je veux dire de
m'adapter à une société en fait qui
n'est pas fait pour pour cette situation
là ce qu'il faut comprendre pour bien
comprendre
cette situation c'est que jusque à la
fin des années non au début des années
60 une section de la moelle épinière et
dans la semaine qui suivait la mort
était là parce qu'il y avait une
infection il y avait une nécroche de
peau où il y avait une infection au
niveau des reins et les personnes
décédées dans la semaine qui suivaient
donc en fait moi je n'ai je n'ai dans où
j'apparais
dans cette forme seulement 20 ans après
que la médecine les progrès de la
médecine ont permis de maintenir les
gens en vie
et donc
je le corps médical la société me promet
l'éventualité de du bonheur ce que
chacun d'entre nous recherchent dans la
vie on est là pour pour emmagasiner un
maximum et se sentir vivre et donc la
société me permet le droit enfin le fait
croire au bonheur à la possibilité
d'avoir une vie sociale à la possibilité
de trouver l'amour à la possibilité
d'avoir des enfants en fait une vie
traditionnelle et en fait c'est ce
discours là équivaut à dire
[Musique]
vous avez la possibilité de courir un
100 m du côté de quelqu'un mais on vous
charge d'un poids de 10 kg au pied et
vous pouvez arriver à courir plus vite
que cette personne c'est de l'utopie
parce que cette situation en fait
engendre un ce qui est dans la vie
traditionnelle normale de chacun d'entre
nous
le moindre geste peut prendre des
proportions et en fait cette situation
engendre le fait que
on gère plus sa vie de paraplégit
tétraplégique qu'on a le droit de vivre
une vie normale je veux dire dans la
société et donc je vis de nombreuses
expériences je passe par le sport pour
handicapés
je fais de la photo voilà je m'inscris
dans une école de photos et donc
parce que j'ai besoin d'être confronté à
la société en dehors du monde des
handicapés parce que pour moi par
exemple ce que j'aime bien à Menton
c'est le fait de ne pas voir de gens en
fauteuil parce que j'ai eu mon image qui
m'aide refléter en fait la réflure
refléter et donc un menton où je vis
depuis 26 ans en fait il y a pas de de
parapluie
des travaux voient pas et donc je vais
dans le monde valide et je suis trois
ans de
et
exposé mais des photos de travaux que je
fais en tant qu'étudiant qui sont
exposés parce que en fait je me découvre
que en fait j'ai toujours fonctionné
dans la photo
voilà et donc je fais de la photo de
mode je ne fais beaucoup de portraits et
je m'épanouis là-dedans sauf que sauf
que j'arrive à une conclusion c'est que
mon le prisme vivant en photo ce
cantonne à celle là je ne peux pas
monter je ne peux pas sauter je ne peux
pas descendre donc pour changer de prise
de vue et pourtant je rêve de vous mais
je n'en fais plus voilà donc
mon père décède en
97 d'un cancer généralisé et je me pose
la question de savoir
qu'est-ce qui me ferait vraiment vibrer
et je fibre toujours dans le mouvement
et à Menton le climat me permet de faire
tous les jours encore maintenant je fais
au moins 10 à 15 km en fauteuil je monte
à Saint-Agnès en fauteuil en 4h30 et je
redescends en 17 minutes donc voilà
en 87
je suis contacté par une association qui
me propose de faire des photos
de la de l'handicap en Afrique de
l'Ouest et donc en fait on prend la
Peugeot 504 un camion chargé de matériel
et on fait le désert d'Algérie le Mali
le Niger le Burkina et de nouveau le
panier par Bamako le périple s'arrête et
donc le l'histoire c'est que là-bas il y
a beaucoup de polluons dans les villes
il y a une sensation la vaccination mais
pas dans les campagnes ça fait que je me
retrouve au milieu de gamins de 4,5 ans
avec des visages d'adultes et
au bout d'une semaine après les avoir
fréquentes et tout le matin tous les
matins dans le centre de rééducation de
Bamako en fait il me saoule tous sur
tous sur moi et vous avez tous ces
petits corps de 4-5 ans qui me sautent
dessus et ça a été des c'est un moment
exceptionnel dans ma vie et en fait ma
vision de l'handicap a changé parce que
dans ce monde
occidental ou c'est la perfection qui
prime la beauté le pouvoir je me rends
compte qu'en fait il y a beaucoup de
choses qui ne sont pas pas montrer je
parle des amis de des années 80 en fait
non et donc voilà ça va modifier ma
perception de la vie et donc je passe
par plusieurs phases et à l'approche de
la de la cinquantaine vers l'âge du 46
ans je le dis mais si ma vie ne va
s'arrêter à ce moment-là
quelle trace j'aurais aimé c'est parce
qu'en fait je
pas donné la vie parce que une des
traces les plus importantes c'est
perpétuer la race humaine et donc comme
mon handicap nous n'autorise pas avoir
d'enfants donc j'aurais pas transmet la
vie donc j'aurais rien laissé et donc en
fait je réalise que la plus belle chose
que je peux faire c'est donner du sens à
cette parapluie et
en fait
au bout de quatre ans
ça c'est moi en Normandie je prends le
départ je n'ai aucune sensibilité dans
mes jambes je n'ai aucune
aucun muscle en fait donc en fait je
calque avec le buste
le matin du 10 août 2011 j'ai 49 ans
toute la nuit du Havre je marche et ce
qui fait que je marche 9 km et demi ce
jour-là c'est parce qu'il y a la presse
et à la télévision moi qui comptait le
marché qu'une journée en fait juste pour
faire un coup médiatique pour pouvoir
parler de la paplégique et stratégie et
en fait
au chauffeur je lui demande de klaxonner
à 19h30
ce qu'il fait je continue à marcher
encore une demi-heure et en fait je
viens de passer le cap de la
cinquantaine un moment critique dans une
vie je viens de le passer debout j'ai
passé les dernières heures de ma
quarantaine debout et ma première
demi-heure de ma cinquantaine debout
pour moi ça a été un
j'ai pas senti arriver les 50 ans le
fait pour traverser du Havre à Menton je
vais me soulever 2 millions de fois
et donc je vais marcher sous des trombes
d'eau devant un camping-car je vais
traverser Paris de nuit pour éviter de
créer des bouchons et je vais marcher à
Avignon sud d'Avignon avec des bandes à
100 km/h dans mon dos ça veut dire que
mes jambes partaient j'ai dû apprendre à
contrôler mon corps dans le vide pour
que les gens retombent en même temps et
j'ai marché de d'Aix-en-Provence
à moins de 16 degrés en fait voilà et
donc je suis arrivé le 24 mars
2012 après 7 mois à Menton et j'ai
réussi mon objectif et donc
la déception elle vient du fait que mon
message est mal interprété on veut me on
me parle de
que je prouve qu'en fait on peut se
dépasser et mon objectif n'est pas de
prouver qu'on puisse dépasser j'ai envie
de parler de ces gens qui se retrouvent
dans cette situation et c'est ça que par
jour en France
ça veut dire en 1500 1600 personnes
voilà et donc ma déception peut pousse
[Musique]
à m'attaquer au symboles de
l'inaccessibilité parce que souvent
quand vous voyez le problème de handicap
c'est un gars en faut deux on met une
photo en noir et blanc avec une volée
d'escalier et là ça c'est bon
je monte 1665 marches de la Tour Eiffel
en 9 heures et 30 minutes au bout de 600
marches mon triceps qui est tellement
petit en fait et mon avant-bras mon
épaule en fait c'est contracte il ne se
décontracte plus donc je suis dans la
douleur et j'ai une chance que j'ai mon
médecin qui est monté avec moi et à
chaque volet d'escalier il est rentré
dans mes muscles
pour décontracter les mus
voilà donc j'ai fait la Tour Eiffel en
2014 et le lendemain
j'ai un cousin qui vit près de tampin en
Floride qui m'appelle et qui me dit si
tu avais fait tout ce que tu as fait aux
États-Unis tu aurais eu une exposition
incroyable je parle à papa pendant un an
je prévois de faire New York Los Angeles
ce qui est une grosse erreur parce qu'en
fait aux États-Unis il y a la côte Est
qui est peuplée et puis à la côte ouest
qui est peuplé et entre les deux c'est
les campagnes et donc je prévois de
mettre un an et demi pour pouvoir faire
ce périple et en fait j'aurais passé une
semaine à avoir une visibilité et puis
pratiquement un an et demi sans
visibilité pour avoir une visibilité
importante dans une semaine donc ça a
été
j'aurais pas atteint mon objectif donc
aux études aux États-Unis j'écris soleil
2 minutes parce que quand j'avais 16 ans
en regardant le ciel couché par terre je
regarde le ciel et je voyais plein des
doigts dans le ciel et je me disais si
un jour je parviens à table une de ses
étoiles construire une échelle qui soit
assez grande pour pouvoir atteindre une
de ses étoiles je vivrai la lumière
éternelle parce que on vit avec la
lumière du soleil et donc ce n'est de
minuit c'est
l'espoir pour moi d'une vie éternelle
j'ai pris contact avec Neurogel en
marche grâce à l'écriture de mon bouquin
et c'est une association dont la femme
du mari est devenue tétraplégique suite
à un accident de voiture elle est partie
en tonneau et elle a une section au
niveau des cervicales ça veut dire
qu'elle ne peut que j'ai les bras et
donc depuis 20 ans il recherche des
récoltes de l'argent pour financer des
chercheurs à Milan au Portugal et à
Menton ici à
la près
5 ans il faut remarcher les gens
en plein chemin de la graisse viscérale
et en
enrichissant ces deux Po et de cellules
souches et donc en fait je vous invite à
aller voir ce ce le YouTube parce que
c'est vraiment exceptionnel et en fait
c'est le covid qui a tout bloqué comme
la bande de mon livre voilà je vous
remercie